we are told there are 10 students in the
poetry club
this week each student wrote two poems
what does the expression 10 times 2
represent and they give us some choices
pause this video and see if you can work
that out
all right so there are 10 students in
the poetry club and each student wrote
two poems
so i would use 10 times 2 to figure out
hey for each of those 10 students if
they each wrote two poems then we have
10 times two total poems
and if we look at the choices that is
choice c right over here
if we look at choice the number of
students the number of students is 10 it
wouldn't be 10 times 2 and then the
number of poems each student wrote well
that's the second piece of information
they each wrote two poems that wouldn't
be 10 times 2 either let's do another
one of these a little bit different this
time
so now we're asked let me scroll this
over a little bit
which problem can we solve with three
times eight
so pause this video and have a go at it
before we do it together
all right now let's read these and see
if you can solve it with three times
eight ellen has eight pieces of gum fair
enough she ate three pieces at school i
hope she didn't swallow the gum that
that could be problematic
how many pieces of gum does ellen have
left
so would you use multiplication for that
the way i would tackle it she has eight
pieces of gum
and if she ate three and we want to
figure out how much gum does she have
left i'm assuming outside of her body
well then i would subtract three from
eight i wouldn't multiply eight by three
so i would rule this one out that's not
going to be my choice i'm not going to
solve this problem with multiplication
or at least by three times eight
brendan has eight t-shirts fair enough
that's about how many i have
he goes to the store to buy three more
t-shirts
how many t-shirts does he have now
would i solve that with multiplication
let's see the way i would solve it is he
has eight shirts
and then he's buying three more i would
add three to figure out how many total
t-shirts he has i wouldn't multiply by
three so i'd rule that out
so let's see how choice c is looking
there are eight chocolates in each box
mike has three boxes of chocolates how
many chocolates are there
so this is interesting so he has three
boxes of chocolates so let me draw those
boxes one box
two box three boxes of chocolate and
each of them have eight chocolates one
two three four five six seven eight one
two three four five six seven eight one
two three four five six seven
well yeah if i want to figure out how
many total chocolates there are i have
three groups of eight i would solve that
by multiplying three times eight so i
like this choice a lot let's do another
example
here
we are told gerald is going to plant a
garden this spring that's a good thing
to be doing he plans to have seven
plants in each row there will be eight
rows
which expression can gerald use to find
the total number of plants needed for
his garden
pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
all right i'll do a little bit of a
drawing i'll do it in green because
we're talking about rows of plants so
seven plants in each row and there will
be eight rows
so
one two three four five six seven seven
plants in each row and then we're going
to have eight rows
so let me copy and paste that
so
so that's
two rows
that's
three rows
that is four rows
getting there
five rows
six rows
seven rows
and
eight
rows
so we don't have to actually calculate
it but the way you could think about it
is you have seven plants in each row and
then you have eight rows of plants
eight rows of plants so if you want to
figure out the total amount you would
multiply eight times seven
and so let's see that's this first
choice right over here you would
multiply 8 times 7 times 7 and 8 plus 7
is definitely not going to give you the
total number of plants here so yeah we
like
using the 8 times 7 and we're done